negli episodi precedenti di residenti
voli ma che ca buttana è un motore
quello ethan sei un po un [ __ ] però
giovanni michele non può che non lo
vedevo fi con lui proprio lui non gli
sparo niente non ci provo neanche lo
vado dritto a madrid entry la notte non
ci arriva quando normale meno male ma
non è meno male di lui proprio lì c'era
verso a si è schiantato contro la porta
beccarino santo nativo che ci siamo
andiamo qua che l'ascensore doppia
l'ascensore secondo me no
se questo si sia l'ascensore si arriva
al duca giorno grazie al tool continuo
supporto ho potuto ampliare i miei
servizi
a lei va bè ragazzi let's go on non so
neanche bene cosa c'è ma arriviamo nel
cuore della cir so neanche che di qua
salto stato sulla porta
no acqua sotto va bene ma ci sarà una
boss fight con quel coso gigante o
contro heisenberg e heisenberg secondo
me è più cazzuto di quello che sembra
anche se magrolino torino tutto fra gli
altri
vedete che con lui so cazzi c'è un sacco
di proiettili di lanciagranate meno male
meno male perché miranda ci considera
come dei ma cosa me ne frega a me la
risposta allora mi conosce di più e dai
lingua di età o scavate che cazzo fai tu
questo è pazzo non mi interessano
entrambi familiare scavate quanto
comunque siamo nelle miniere ragazze
sempre più dark souls avevo già detto
miliardo di volte ma almeno lamentazione
è sì però avete rotto il cazzo voi che
state qua questa cosa c'era sempre
fatevi una camomilla a tutti quanti che
sto passando io questa non è
l'accoglienza giusta oh che bello
l'ultimo colpo per l'ultimo zombie very
nice
veramente di cristallo ok polvere da
sparo di mandello beh allora tutto sto
casino per un grimaldello n'è valsa la
pena va bene allora se così come sto
posto non era abbastanza krypi entriamo
anche nel nei nei tunnel che tanto tanto
peggio di così non è che può andare
perfetto lo vado giù su diverse dove
donna ma c'è qualcosa lo faccio saltare
per gli ziti bomber non l'ho ancora
usato una bomba artigianale contro un
nemico mai solo per far saltare sti cosi
cristallo grande e viva di viani te
questo questo mi sa di boss fight e
ragazzi questo mi sa di boss fight
preparatevi perché qua qua succedono
casini come questo è un dato di fatto
proprio
eccola
picchia che cazzo e ancora chi sei
porca vacca un cornuto quante quanto 6
grosso zio una donna che voglia di usare
i proiettili da mani le palle no in
chiavi butto come pezzo faccio madonna
loschi ma come faccio come faccio non
posso non posso di usare una bomba non
posso non ce la faccio non posso la ii
minchia ragazzi usare ma perché non ci
non ci passa da qua ma come dovrei fare
non posso
niente non mi pare anche passa ok
perfetto sarà questo uno è caduto
l'altro no proviamo è morto mamma mia
ragazzi mamma mia ho usato turno più
granate le ho usate su di chiamata le
dico che le granate me le tengo i
proietti venite tutto quello che dico
che mi tengo poi lo uso tutto è
possibile basta basta sti tizi basta per
cortesia
basta sevizi veramente me lo chiedono
tutto me stesso che devo fare qua e mi
tranciate passo che non uscire afferma
ecco ragazzi fa ci aspetta
ok minchia lo spera i cosi e un po
grossa la nuova scheda nvidia non so se
ve ne siete ancora allora vetrina i beni
funge anche la scala bene ora che
abbiamo ora che ho finito tutti i colpi
boss fight c'è di te mi servirebbe
adesso proprio adesso sì che c'è proprio
il momento della boxe fight quando ho
finito i proietti non ho più niente
intanto mi esce dalla cee colò
gigantesco deprima sicuro no
chi è che strano non sto ben capendo
dove devo finire cos'è sta roba
spegni la ventola sparacino e mi stava
risucchiando la ventola ma ti sembra
normale
ho fatto danno ma chissenefrega tanto
guarda e ci è mancato poco si dov'è che
dobbiamo andare
questo è il dissipatore della 390 va
dove tira di qua di sotto di ciò che
devo fare qui non capisco ok di qua
effetto mamma mia ragazzi
difficile fare il tecnico è comunque
studiato informatica per questo erano
tutte così le verifiche i sistemi quindi
tutto sto casino per che cosa la pena
non mi disp un tavolo gigante nome
spunta non sono ancora uscito in tutto
questo pensate
c'è un pulsante rosso mi andava di
preparare per richiamare l'ascensore che
palm cielo ai megafoni omnibus li ha
messi ovunque stime gato potenti sarà la
figlia e altoparlante per tua figlia e
poi tutto il sito smettila non preoccupa
il fatto fine proietti un seno rus per
uccidere miranese l'unico non aver
ancora capito quanto è potente tua ma
perché è perché figlia di mia moglie che
la ruta in grembo mia moglie che era
stata infettata per quello lo so stampo
per una chiave tutto il suo bordello per
uno stampo c'è ma veramente siamo seri
ma sono tornato dove c'è il duca la
campanella ricreazione a posto devo
ritornare a per un altro ostacolo cosa
ancora cosa ancora cosa ancora
è successo mi chiami fa mi far pierre e
male anche tu che già è difficile
la chiave del cavallo non fare quella
ciò due porte da aprire questa chiave 2
mi chiedevo tornado vero prima del buio
perché sempre buio quando torna nei
posti porco demonio cosa succede
no non mi spunta non fatemi spuntare
qualcuno no no no no vi prego promosso
ve lo chiedo per cortesia ve lo chiedo
per cortesia
io vabbè finito sono morto
raga la vedo un po complicata ok non lo
faccio lo faccio ma sei bellissimo mi sa
che lo faccio fuori solo perchè cielo
davanti un asterisco a farlo fuori
contro ci metto per fucile a pompa
secoli la precisione ci metto poco
relativamente con la poppa ci metto una
seria pensavo molto di più ma se ne
pensavo molto di più duro non ci ha
messo così tanto la strada meno male
nicchia che culo ok
la smettiamo di rompere le palle per
favore ve lo chiedo
madonna non mi ha preso per niente
che culo ok poi possiamo finire per
favore lo chiedo per cortesia non ho più
lo più proprio finito finito 5
proiettili
quindi per favore smettiamola perché
sennò c'era un'altra chiave che non
avevo utilizza qua stanza di heisenberg
min che quella ok
vai vai vai vai ce l'abbiamo fatta credo
tutto sto bordello per la stanza di
heisenberg c'è io veramente per entrare
la sostanza di fabbricarsi la chiave
c'è il massimo della sicurezza proprio
che succede c'è gente dentro accidente
posso farla fuori da qua stato da far
fuori dopo buongiorno madonna che è la
sua porta
lui un po meno pur sapendo mi ha colpito
34 fisico all di ragazzi c'è più niente
non ho niente no veramente ragazzino
niente ho finito tutto devo usare una
mina antiuomo
a meno che non posso creare meli non me
li posso che al milan tv finiti colpi
enea storia vera questo fisico come sia
così mina
ciao ha funzionato almeno non per tutti
provocare il coltello
ho finito tutti i colpi sono nella merda
dimmi che ci sono proiettili choir
favore che sennò scarti arrugginiti
posso farmeli si pensò di fucile parte
meccanica barra ok nice
ho solo più due colpi di fucile a pompa
e poi ho finito cos'è che stava proposte
sia per i limiti valore della sparo in
una stanza chiusa questa non solo per
andare avanti ma [ __ ] questa roba
che va col cilindro barra cilindro
combina mais martello meccanico perfetto
martello di heisenberg di grande valore
meno male almeno ad almeno ho un sacco
di soldi ma non ho proiettili quindi non
è proprio il massimo
comunque con la chiave dovrebbe chiamare
il duca se arrivo di qua mi chiedevo
rifare il giro non mi ricordo più dove
non mi ricordo come siccome ci si arriva
proprio matematica
no ragazzi
chi cazzo è questo ma siete matti
ma chi è devo andare lì poi tra l'altro
proprio andare lì si sono scemi se n'è
andato
minchia di la destra via via via non
dovevo andare assistito andare il tuo
amico normale ok ok sta succedendo
ragazzi per farvelo beh veramente per
favore ve lo chiedo perché vi supplico
cosa faccio nomi ha panina ma ce ne sono
due uno di camilla non possono scendere
e salire rimango qua cosa faccio scusami
no ragazzi hanno capito il cazzo
parliamo ma così ci sono che si sono
perduti il cervello sono matti tutti
quanti ma cosa dovrei fare io qua ciao
non entri quale ero chiedo per un amico
gli fa una domanda seria cosa dovrei
fare scappare
ok quanto devo scappare per aggirare lo
zio
ok qua non dirvi che c'è anche qualche
c'è ora che si stava sta andando
indietro non riesce a uscire
posso uscire io da lì per continua non
devi uscire ma io lo scrivo driblato ok
però quello era quell'altro a sinistra
qua c'è ancora l'altro di come lo triplo
fammi passare mi ha fatto passare meno
famosa ce l'ho fatta già fatta ma fatto
passa mi ha colpito e mi ha fatto un po
male ma ne è valsa la pena sei rimasto
così nicchia nicchia era un po grosso
quello signor duca e lei non mi avverte
touch cisl va proprio da fatti 21 non
possiamo non posso vendere mentre si
muove strafare e peccato minchia chissà
cosa davano quelli come come premio non
me ne frega niente averlo perché per
farli fuori devo usare 20 proiettili
guarda ciò 12 proiettili e lanciagranate
ma guarda nel dubbio non mi ritengo se
stessi godi martello di heisenberg
45.000 buono e di tutto ha visto
bombardi ecco una bomba artigianale la
teresa una sola perché secondo me non è
male per il resto tieniti tutto tutto
quanto alla prossima volta sì perché
teoricamente aspetto che mi dia ancora
qualcos'altro sono me secondo me c'è
ancora qualcos'altro che mi può dare lo
zio aspetto di comprare quelle tempo
ancora i soldi non ho colpi
non ho quindi mi dei colpi ti prego
quello che servirebbe dove stiamo
andando ragazzi carico merci s
finiamola qui non mi mandare altri come
quelli sì no no no no ma che faccio sono
morto i sei scaricato
bye bye bye bye bye la croce madonna noi
la b non avevo perso sono morto finito
come faccio una faccia come faccio come
faccio questa trovata usato come faccio
come faccio come faccio una faccia come
faccio una faccia una maggiore scolo
morta ragazzi non ce la farò ma devo
farlo fuori non penso questo mi fa fuori
muri tra l'altro nono incredibile da
mina mina antiuomo
ok se arriva fra usarla perché non ho
idea ci si guarda estate sono stato mi
sono fatto salta in aria e ne è valsa la
pena mette un'altra tanto ci passi di e
sta morendo
tipo un fluido orchi mythos no che è
perfetto creato un'altra cosa che non
devo creare sono morto
e stato bello giocare con voi
non gliene frega nulla c'è qualche
europa
lui se ne sport e proprio devo devo
schivarlo quando carica è l'unica prova
a colpirlo da dietro perché mi sembra
che da dietro forse qualcosa di ne frega
di più non troppo è però meno male che
si muove lento almeno quello glielo
spaccati tipo 9 è andata a fuoco uomo è
andata andata andato lo zio esplode
minchia
mi chiamino no non posso curarmi tra
l'altro
è la madonna l'ho colpito pure sono
fiero di me no no no no non so però mi
ha sparato stato punizione pistola e
munizioni pistola grazie
non so veramente una seconda pistola si
che lo uccido questo grazie delle grazie
veramente non solo per ringraziarti non
so veramente che dire senza parole l'ho
fatto fuori almeno no no no no non
assolutamente ma posso crearmi la
soluzione mediche ok una tabella neri
niente è morto orali e mori quanto tempo
cucina precisione ma veramente
gli ho sparato tutti lanciagranate che
avevano più vi dico solo questo
questo fa
tremando sta facendo largo
non ho capito ma è lo stesso
no stop ci ho provato
sarebbe stato di castro è morto non solo
uccidono scopo veramente con l'ultimo
proietti non stop con l'ultimo
proiettile da cecchino non stop con
l'ultimo proiettile da cecchino cuore
meccanico complesso affacciò gas
ho finito 12 pro basta mente cosa vuol
dire 12 proiettili di lanciagranate 12
sono ho finito io non posso più fare
niente non ho più pistola non ho più
vicino ma niente ci capiterà magnum ok
va bene ma non è che puoi far fuori il
boss che heisenberg adesso dovrò far
fuori con quei proiettili non ho più
niente
sì caro beh grazie ma don reagan finito
tutto quello che ha persono sono
veramente non ho più nulla solo per il
fucile doppietta
porca vacca il compresa solo un sacco di
salari scambierei tuttas tutti sti soldi
per dei proiettili che non sarebbe molto
interessante che devo fare qua qua c'è
qualcosa aspetta che segue
bombe ce l'abbiamo fatta siamo arrivati
al termine di st cacchio di fabbrica 60
anni le fabbriche dove sto andando
ok va bene tutta la gies mica spero che
mi diano un carro armato per le fasi
finali visto gioco perché non so più
come andare avanti o meno male se esci
di qua si può uscire l'astro posto di
merda vi supplico a questa era la
presenza di iniziare ok
apri chiusa
macché ma no e lo zio e lo zio e magneti
ma cos'è lo zio ayane lui attrae tutti
gli oggetti magnetici un casino lo
faceva anche prima col cacciavite
ricordo male
grazie non ti arredi a proprio lui
scende le scale così che figata
d'aquitania quindi ora sparisse bravo
bravo bravo bravo sparargli mi sembra la
cosa migliore
bravissima non mi ha neanche ucciso ha
deciso di
ok sì sì me ne vado perché me ne vado me
ne vado volentieri
me ne vado molto volentieri arrivederci
sì tanto si va sì tanto poi e
soprattutto per 8 km nell'acqua
ero in una fabbrica dove cacchio soul
finito in ohio per la starna mi devo
rifatta fabbricano de prego fatemi
uscire dalle fogne non lo so con la
barchetta classica di michela marchetti
navazzo di nuovo canale di scarico
vi prego ditemi che posso uscire da
qualche parte che la barchetta perché no
la barchetta no però non mi fate fare
pezzi perché non ho più niente
fatemi uscire di qua voglio tornare a
villabate riuscire
voglio uscire dalla fabbrica per quanto
ostica st parte dio sa notissimo
heisenberg ma ci piace comunque sei
stato bravo a spararli proprio
intelligenti con cristo che è stato
detto di lasciar per tonalità grazie
d'introd danni dei colpi almeno se ne
frega chris ha ucciso mia moglie e
figlio di [ __ ] ti che ucciderà i miei
non era lei come non era lei era mirando
era milan da ma come aveva preso di
seriate la presa dei suoi sembianze ha
cambiato aspetto e ha finto di essere
minchia che roba che sia sopravvissuta
quindi sono qui per finire il ma dai
quindi non era milano e balilla mama
sarah ivano e successi che sono merito
dei fatti e so che la forchettina vestì
messo immerso è infatti è già abbastanza
complicato senza coinvolgere civili
perché noi crisi sta succedendo non era
mia era miranda che prende miranda
prende le sembianze degli altri va bene
quindi ha finto di essere mia moglie non
era lei che è morta all'inizio e dove mi
sa che deve delle spiegazioni
la meco la chiave ma ha finto di essere
mia anche nel residenti volo 7 non ho
capito o nell'otto tonellotto anche
perché ci ha fatto una figlia questo
villaggio mostri gli squilibrati e tutto
però succede avevo in mente sta con una
specie di folla esperimento con la muffa
come in louisiana maledizione pensavo di
poter salvare la mia famiglia non posso
fuggire non posso fare nulla non è
esattamente così si chiama veramente da
un carro armato che stavo scherzando
prima ma veramente genoa tra mi ha
inviato quelle foto poco fuori milano
guarda le tette
rose o cazzo dobbiamo andare calma i
miei uomini la tengono d'occhio s ma
hanno preso dia figlia tu non capisci
non potresti mai farcela da solo
controbilancia minchia che è figlio
c'era veramente il carro armato ma
cacchio io resto qui a finire di
piazzare gli esplosivi tu prendi
l'ascensore ci vediamo all'ultimo chiaro
va bene e ti prometto che ci
riprenderemo 2 fa bene insieme
ok grande credo che lo faremo e quando
troverò milan ma sarà bravo con la
pistolina di merda bravo ai fatti da
riso anche lui faceva che fai ridere
però bene allora prendi questo e fammi
un carro armato prendo non fare cazzate
vado col carro armato ma veramente mela
da meno ma stai scherzando
non si torna indietro
no non ci credo mi è andato veramente un
carro armato rega sto morendo dal ridere
io l'ho detto prima per scherzo ma non
me la mia veramente un carro armato
vendo premuto ma non ho capito per cosa
a per entrare dentro perché potevi
scegliere di non entrarci fallo e
polimeri un combattimento ad armi pari
ma qualche l'ha fatta la crisi ma tu sei
un sacco di tutorial in generale bravo
madonna meno male perché non avevo più
proiettili sotto poco tempo lega pro
nostra vita è una vox vice da sto male
bellissimo notate set ma li sta facendo
qualcosa non sto facendo niente
questa heisenberg comunque
gigante di ferro aiuto
ok ed è in atto alcun carro armato
cristo cioè pensate
madonna buio perché sotto il braccio
anche l'altro nice pensare una bella
volta che non ragazzi non vedo altri
rifiuti devono essere lento sono lento
si
dai
giuro non sto capendo quale l'altro
punto debole perché non
è saltato e saltato un po sta prendendo
fuoco nice
mi sa che sei incazzato un attimo va
bene me lanciato intercooler e spara o
che vi opera dentro del terrore
mi hanno fatto fuori tutto ragazzo molto
sono morto sono morto travolto e senza
tra fabbrica aiuto
vabbè si certo certo ma che cazzo devo
fare ma pur copie scusami una domanda su
qual cosa devo fare
vieni spiegami come come col fucile una
doppietta
meno male che avevo un po di
lanciagranate ancora ma vediamo se serve
ma posso crearmi lapsi minchia meno male
pur assicurati curati cura corti del
approvato
e morto
e morto è morto non è morto
mi hanno tirato un altro nel dubbio è
morto non è morto ma va bene
beh
ma infatti io volevo farlo e lui che è
stupido
il carro armato l'ho visto prendere al
volo
esatto esatto esatto
bravissima bellissimo anche se litio che
boss fight the box mike bones piper
bellissima mamma mia che spettano
ragazzi mi inchino bellis
meno male che ho tirato fuori dei colpi
di lancia granate che ho usato tutti
tutti noi non più neanche uno eisenberg
e cristallizzati non ne ho più neanche
uno ma in compenso è morto heisenberg
amiche che figata
i colpi tratti altre precisissimi non
avevo più niente
no niente un petardo sistemato a tarda
ora trovino miranda e mi riprenderò fra
esilio è troppo pericoloso
aspettami recapito è una è una e una
luce è un'allucinazione non con la
pistola
ecco qui non è non è chi pensi che sia
rapina è la cosa più importante per
destro è tutto per me e anche per me
senza is under
hai perso la tua vita
che cosa pensi di fare
non lo so ma salverà un rose non stai
mai nulla giusto proprio come quando ho
preso cosa infatti cioè non ci ha mai
dato record chi sei dove rosicky center
ha spiegato la signorina miranda molto
grosso ecco ora basta ha creato degli
alberi
ti ricordi di evelyn e del suo potere su
una messa rose la sua rosa è la forma
vera e completa di imparerà ad avere
pieno controllo della mia legno crepa
stronza con la pistolina fai paura ma
ancora sconvolti agitare rose si salverà
il mega micete a memoria di ogni cosa
lei rinascerà nuovamente come mia figlia
è la mia bambina non la tua 26 poteva
dare perché rosa e così speciali e mia
figlia merito dei suoi genitori
anche tu sei davvero speciale ma non hai
più nulla da insegnare
la tua utilità cometaria
vieni fuori affrontavi ma grazie la tua
mamma ma infatti c'è già morto gran
quello tuo minchiate rottura di
conservare un se non voglio così è
finita dove c'era una volta la cerimonia
sarà completa e io diventerò la sua vera
madre legate dal sangue per l'eternità
che schifo raga ma dai
se non voglio persona muoio così è
finita com'è possibile
spiegatemi adesso non può neanche il
ballottaggio si salva ma adesso i miei
sogni si avvererà lordo luca finalmente
è giunto il momento in cui potrò
ripetere in via fino al meno male questo
è il finale buono infine le confermo che
i tenui ad essere nati da tolto al cuore
recuperato delle prove
mi spiego tutto avvia la condivisione
vai
siamo stati molto avventati ieri abbiamo
colpito miranda mentre era trasformata
ma non l'abbiamo uccisa che immaginavo
potesse fingersi morta miranda poteva
avere infettato ethan quindi ho portato
lui
eros con noi ma il veicolo che li
trasportava è stato attaccato quando
sono arrivato
ethan e rosa erano spariti
l'ultima volta che ho contattato ethan
ho sentito la voce di miranda l'ha
ammazzato e la pagherà molto caro
quindi alla fine piuttosto casinò e poi
ma tirato fuori il cuore sono morto e
quindi ora capital sa quando finirà
bravo che parte in sigaro di tutto
da tre anni proprio a chiudere questa
storia e tiranni sono troppi
fermeremo caduti la squadra è bruciata
tutto sto casino per niente quindi a
meno che non mi a meno che non mi
facciano controllare chris ma dubito
così la bsa sa è già qui non hanno perso
tempo a un po di meta gli erbai
christine no insomma c'è nessun cambio
ma la al sigaro eliminare miranda e
salvare rosa
questa è la missione ed è vietato
fallire merci nella mischia gente
proprio come ai vecchi tempi muoviamoci
dei nine scopri che ci fa qui la bsa
indaga ok ok ci penso io
quindi adesso sono uccidi miranda sono
sono chris ma che ti si desidera
chiarire dice l'episodio di residenti ci
vediamo giovani con l'ultimo episodio
spero che vi sia piaciuto cos'ha detto
ragazzi lasciato un momento è un mi
piace se vi è piaciuto il video di
schede al canale e noi nonostante il
povero vita ci vediamo al prossimo video
domani ciao ragazzi
[Musica]